agree well speaking of food as Black
History Month comes to a close we're
ending with some really delicious
looking food items that's right we've
got Lauren negrady live this morning at
Calabash African kitchen at Rainbow and
Oaky with some tasty treats Lauren good
morning to you and some tasty drinks
apparently as well yes
oh good morning yeah we've got great
food and great drinks here as well at
calabas African kitchen it's been a
great time it's been a year that they've
been open now I'm joined with the owner
of Lee Fisher I'm talking about the
community reception here you've had did
Las Vegas Community
um have oh did most of my customers 60
of them have never tried African food
but they still want to venture and that
the support has been overwhelming
they've been overwhelming kids adults
everybody is coming to calabasa African
kitchen I really really appreciate all
of them their support and I apologize to
some of them that sometimes our wait
time is a little bit African food that a
little bit longer so you have to when
you come into calabazia it's not fast
food you have to be a little bit pissed
and but I appreciate everything from my
community they have been really
supportive yeah you know like they say
good things come to those who wait and
speaking on that let's get into some of
this here now it was we were remarking
you know in Hispanic culture I was
calling this empanadas but for you guys
yeah we call it in Gambia and Senegal we
call it fataya that's amazing and so
let's get into what this is here so you
said there's some different fillings yes
some are vegetarians some beef Chicken
and Seafood amazing okay so it's a
little bit of a of a surprise here of
what's going to be in this one okay here
we go
I got b a few I got beef too
it's great and there's even a platanos
but plantains as well
some great things look forward to here
as we're like chewing out there
really good and the sauce that comes
with it is really good I make it with
roasted Peppers red peppers and eggplant
perfect really good oh it looks
fantastic here I mean you guys I'm
enjoying myself it's such a great thing
to have a diverse you know thing another
dining option in the community so again
live in Las Vegas Lorna gritty eight
news now back to you guys
thank you